we begin this hour doing a little
shopping if you will this weekend is
bracketed by some of the most notable
shopping days of the year black friday
and cyber monday and today is small
business saturday but even without the
special deals these events promise
there's evidence american consumers are
very much in a buying mood adobe
estimates americans spent as much as
nine billion dollars yesterday we're
joined now by cbs news senior business
business i can say it analyst joel
schlesinger jill good morning to you
the numbers sound good 9 billion sounds
good what can we expect this holiday
season
i think it's going to be a brisk season
we're looking at say a 7 to 9 percent
increase from last year on the holiday
season in total that usually runs from
november through the first week of
january of that we're looking at uh
e-commerce being say 11 to 15 you want
to put the numbers on it it's about 1.3
trillion dollars of total spending 215
billion of which is e-commerce it will
be strong a lot of people heading back
to the stores because they're worried
they can't get their items shipped in
time
so what is fueling the jump is is that
it alone
well let's let's look at this i'm going
to quote sondheim on this day you know
you need a good foundation unless
otherwise it's risky from the start and
here's the foundation that consumers are
coming off with they've got wage
increases so we've seen wages go up
there's excess savings we've seen
savings pile up during the pandemic era
and what's really interesting is people
just want to go out and quote unquote be
normal they want to actually shop be in
the stores and feel good so that has
really fueled a very strong end to this
year and i think retailers are very
happy as a result
people may have more in their savings
accounts they may have less in their
portfolio now jill after yesterday's
day on wall street worst day for the dow
since late last year worst day for the s
p since february how concerned are you
right now about yesterday's big drop
well obviously this had a lot to do with
the surge of a new variant in south
africa this really spooked investors but
remember this is one day of trading it
was a two and a half percent drop across
the board not pleasant but we should
really look at this in the total year to
date you know right now u.s stocks are
up over 20 percent this year piled on
top of the 16
gain from the year before the more than
almost like about 29 from the year
before that so we're looking at a
three-year stretch here that we have not
seen since the late 90s i wouldn't be
too spooked yet but again we've talked
about this over and over the path of the
virus will actually create the path for
the economy and that goes for the global
economy and the u.s economy
jill real quickly before we let you go
so with this strong holiday season
predicted what impact might that have
could that be good for our overall
economy then
it sure will it looks like that the
delta variant which really slowed growth
down in the third quarter that we've
kind of come to the other side of that
the fourth quarter growth is on pace to
be about five percent that means that
this year we will see growth of about
six percent in the u.s economy thank
goodness because last year the economy
actually shrank by 3.4 percent so good
news for the end of the year gang
okay jill thank you very much